welcome to this video covering the first
round of the norm a chess tournament
2014 the second big highlight is here in
Norway the most important one being the
chess olympiad in August but the Norway
chess tournaments of D has an excellent
field of players some compiled we have
most of the world's top layer CM m
including Magnus Carlsen the only yeah
okay we have to to a very prominent
names missing Nakamura and in Thailand
an uncertainty in preparation for the
for the match which is not yet scheduled
and Jenna camera for some reason was not
invited or not available not not sure
what he's doing at the moment um okay so
let's start with coverage I'll do this
tournament which is nine nine rounds and
I do this in a formative doing a game of
the day which is a bit more thoroughly
presented and the other games I'll do in
a very quick very quick way just giving
a brief overview what happened and maybe
point out one or two key moments if
there was a big possibility that one
side probably not realized on point out
the main errors um first came to look at
his Aronian plain white against ACTA
stein may be a player you do know he's
some been always number one player for a
very long time time obviously until
magnus carlsen came into the scene he's
also been the first trainer of magnus
carlsen so i'm quite an interesting
player on the other hand if you look at
his rating 26 28 did an outsider here in
this field so you will have a tough time
and first game black against Aronian
it's not easy yeah we get a Quincy
in and in fact that this is a line that
has also been played by cards number of
times especially blitz and rapid so not
a big surprise that uh Christine is
playing this this is all a very solid
set up like a setting up this ball of
pawns on the second-ranked I'm on the
third rank from from his perspective um
and tries to be very flexible in the
center and he can initiate counter play
like with b5 d5 just according to
circumstances the bishop body falls of
course a funny place piece but it has a
nice position now and I kristyne get
some some play in the center he had
prepared c5 and yeah he aronia didn't
find anything better than to change the
structure and this way now we have a
completely symmetrical structure which
is not very favorable for the bishop
pair it's not so easy to make your use
of the bishop that way naughty wonder
some move that I liked he gained some
space in the center but now we have this
oops we have this formation here in the
center with those some squares I'm not
quite sure why and like green hmm again
green yeah the squares d5 and deform are
the interesting squares where Knights
will pop up and both sides regroup their
nights to get to this crucial squares
and well they are so strong on on their
squares that it's tough to keep them
there for a long time interesting moment
here's this the spot where artists I'm
place look before quite an interesting
move from an exchange sacrifice just
putting in the look on the square where
it is so ya can be captured um and it's
a bit difficult not to capture it in the
long
on and yeah aronia took it but this is
really a good sacrifice look at this the
queen is immediately attacked twice
needs to retreat and if we look at this
we see that whites rooks don't have much
to do but quite sure why this keeps
happening White's rooks don't have much
to do they basically have no useful role
while blacks rook is having this useful
pressure on the a file and on top of it
there is also the possibility that those
pawns can get dangerous read relatively
quickly we had a transformation here
after odka Stein put the knight on c3
aronia and had to just take his and get
to this position where we had to
material equality and here draw was
agreed both sides really cannot make
much progress at first you might think
the night is somewhat more dangerous in
combination with the Queen but why just
stays in this position and does nothing
there is nothing to play for so a good
start for artists on gaining a draw
against Aronian Aronian certainly not
too enthusiastic about the result but
there may be was not much to be done
next game the world champion carson
against Giri an English opening year was
played and very quickly we get to a
position that looks a bit like a goon
felt but with white having the pawn or
III check it's some pretty yeah that's
that's use some and a very young common
structure here in the English it
sometimes used by white players who
don't want to have a pure green felt and
want to yet try to outplay like in a
somewhat slower fashion
we we came to to this position here
where white at first looks a bit more
active he's got this Bishop always
looking at the pawn and active Queen on
d5 it turns out though that relatively
quickly we get to this position with the
Queen on c6 where white gets the pollen
c6 but has a hard time to keep it after
c7 rook c8 yeah how would you keep the
pawn yeah council finds a nice way to
keep the pawn he played f4 and after age
6 just retreated the night in order to
hear exchange to put them to offer an
exchange sacrifice and this was actually
played White has sacrificed the exchange
and has established this nice poem on c7
yeah how to assess the position it's
probably equal um we see that Giri is
quickly pushing the ape on to to get
counter play or at least set up some
device for counter play so that white
cannot easily maneuver around and do
whatever he pleases if he moves away
from the Queen side then the acorn will
actually just advance the problem is
this is all very nice for light if we
look at this night be 5 cover c7 but
it's difficult from this position to
further improve you would like to maybe
push push pause him to gain more space
get the King involved and ultimately if
the part is on e5 maybe play 96 but the
problem is black always has a counter
play and he's initiating that right now
he now threatens rook e7 and once the
root get expelled from d7 it's pretty
much over in terms of an edge so night
87 was played attacking on CH the rook
basically forcing it back and now again
well the night is hanging so
it needs to go back and rook c8 and you
already have to sneak your suspicions
and you're right here draw was a grid or
let's say it's it's not avoidable
anymore white really has no way away
forward Tim as after rook c8 hear
something like this is not on you to
rookie seven and now it's it's a problem
white will yeah white will be the one to
to to to struggle for draw here so not a
good idea yeah it's just the draw
nothing you can do about it carzon tried
hard with the exchange sack but there
was nothing nothing to be done okay next
game is swidler kramnik that i look
briefly we got an english opening the
reversed dragon reversed Sicilian and
this is an opening that chronic has
played a number of times suspect in fact
we follow a very well-known game up to a
seven point we can actually go to this
here exactly here we haven't do musafir
crumbling place tonight f7 he had played
the move Knight he ate before 98 funny
enough in a in a very important game
when he played magnus carlsen in the
London chess classics 2009 and lost a
very interesting game afterwards um it
was some it was certainly not a pleasant
memory but ok night f7 was the
improvement or let's say the the novelty
that he played today here against
Whitlam it needs to be noted thats
witless of course a traditional one a
four player but in recent years he has
branched out to play basically any
opening at least he's mixing things and
as he said well d4 and ce4 are the
perfect anti-villain openings which is
an M nice way to put it does not want to
face the ballooning and scrum make soap
Lacey for ya here we have a really
really long positional struggle um we're
both sides try to play on the queenside
the King side is not much happening and
we got some traits coming here with the
queenside relatively quickly getting
getting cleared and the whole time it
always was a bit about equal you could
only look for sort of a microscopic
advantage for some point for some player
here we got two opposite catholic
bishops and draw a grid yeah pretty much
a non-game there was some fight between
move 20 and 30 when it was about those
little points that you can you can you
can spot for gaining very small
advantages but there was never really
happening much so on a draw in this game
yeah next one is kayaking to pile of
which was actually a rather interesting
game but I will focus on on another one
the game we shook Kara wanna which will
be them it's a game of the day the one I
cover a bit more detailed so briefly
kayaking to par love we had this funny
line the Queens gambit with III which is
gaining some popularity simply because
the yeah the main lines like like here
are not giving right very much or Bishop
f4 is also tough to get an advantage
with so what people try to play III year
tube to just get a game typical of the
let's say the Magnus cards an era of
chess
getting game is good enough yeah okay
why does trying to play this kind of
color Zuka toor dal PO out ball hehe
Joan what set up bishop on b2 bishop on
d3 is what white is trying to do and he
managed that black is going for a fee
and chattels quite funny after he has
played e6 early but it still makes sense
to put the bishop oppose the default on
yet we get a typical position with
hanging pawns where I'm right here why
does enjoying some activity is even
pushing f4 here so white has some
activity and certainly got what he
wanted an interesting fighting position
with lots of pieces on the board and not
many theoretical lines that you need to
get sort of navigate around two to get
the board clear to a draw yeah and the
the interesting point arises relatively
quickly here when kayaking initiates
this big breakthrough in the center I'm
not quite sure how good this moves
really is it is very very principled
right from from this position their
ideas after the capture which obviously
happened only move there is Bishop g4 at
first you think occasion this is winning
an exchange yeah in a way it is but it
leads to two very crazy positions like
also could have taken on c4 what did
play deform and if you look at this now
you see that okay white has some1 the
exchange but as a result like has very
nice bishops those two and the three
points that widens there all week so
this is a tricky position to play very
likely like we'll get a pawn back in
this case it was the a porn very
difficult to
keep the material probably impossible
and here we see a further simplification
to an end game where black has the
bishop pair and upon form the exchange
and yeah if anybody white is still a bit
better as the rooks might prove to be a
more effective in the long run but it's
very difficult to win um for white we
had some some further trades and went to
this end game and I'm not totally sure
and the thing is i have from obviously
some time restraints i'm not totally
sure if whiter maybe can do something
here yeah i just like you are getting
the bishop to have six playing on the
back rank I don't know it it seems tough
to do maybe it is just the draw but I
wouldn't be totally surprised if some
some person with the lots of time on
their handsome would find some way
forward in the game check check we had
some more trades with rooks traded which
is probably not helping white very much
and around him it became apparent that
there is simply nothing happening yeah
I'm judges we had a total of clearance
of pawns and draw a grid if anything
what may be needed to operate with the
bishop coming somewhere here and keep
black from advancing with g5 I'm not
criticizing White's play I'm just saying
if if there was a way forward it it was
a bit different than what happened in
the game but it was certainly not not an
easy task I mean the computer does not
find anything and I think also the
commentator said okay probably it's a
draw okay so this is this were the forum
for quick replay games let's go to
Greece oka wanna
and this is what I'm going to look at in
a bit more detail um yeah hard to to
predict any opening here it looks like
Kara wanna wants to play the green part
it's not a king's indian player but the
Green Party is playing regularly but the
grease shock is going for g3 so a
fianchetto um yeah now black in fact has
a big choice he can still play a green
card with d5 he can play c5 he can play
the Kings Indian many possibilities but
karana goes for a c5 setup which I found
a very average if I'd very interesting
to play against g3 a.m. when i was
playing this this kind of setup is black
mostly playing the king's indian off
against g3 i always like to play the the
greenford when it wasn't so totally in
fashion and nowadays i would probably
play what Kara wanna is playing here
going for Ben Oni type of set up an
interesting point is that we took place
d5 an interesting point is that after
Knight f3 black has various interesting
moves that he can play one is this this
funny line where you attacks you for
quickly i can very much recommend this
line for black it's very interesting to
play and at the moment why does not have
anything though it's very interesting to
do the other thing that black can play
is the strange-looking Mussolini 5 check
it's a bit of a forgotten line but still
interesting Knight c3 there's 94 and
something like Bishop d2 can be answered
back we'd be sick sort of attacking
taking both pawns it's an interesting a
little line queen a5 check yeah but d5
was played and I think Grisha gets doing
that because he wants to avoid those
kind of things especially the line with
the capture and later
Quincy 7s giving white some headaches at
the moment to have to play for any edge
yeah okay kawana is going to to the
modern benoni in fact here after d5
there is also the move order d 69 f 3 b
5 however your wife can also play Knight
c3 to prevent b5 I just wanted to
mention that you can also sometimes mix
in banco flavors note that the immediate
b5 is not a good idea due to d6 winning
material ok so we got a bun in benoni
and here come on our plate rook e8 yeah
and the next move Grisha is really a bit
a bit curious you played a form that's
interesting I was a bit surprised about
that normally you only play a 4 if black
has played a 6 at the typical type of
move move pea black plays a six and
white very often almost automatically
place the moon's a 4 to prevent b5 here
white Oh ever is just playing a for
without being provoked quite quite
interesting it has been played before
but this is far less popular than the
main moves with John still 92 and
probably Bishop f4 it's interesting to
note that Kara wanna as white is also
playing this position he had played
Bishop f4 against Nakamura in the Zurich
chest challenge and I think it was
februari this yeah i probably have
covered this F cough cough this
tournament not the game maybe i'm not
i'm not sure was a very complicated game
um note that it is becoming more and
more common for my tia to actually allow
the move 94 in former times it was
always thought that you should actually
prevent the smooth with 92 but this very
much clocks
pure development and grief shocks a4 is
a very interesting way to ignore 94 as
it after this also had weakened the
before spot where black very often can
can use the rook and in fact after 90 to
look before the rook got to perform very
quickly um funny position of the rook
after Luke a 2-1 idea of a for obviously
White has the idea to trap the rook b3
Bishop a three um but as we will see
this is not a big problem black now
played the move a5 not a very typical
been only move and in this concrete
position it's a novelty considering the
time spent however probably maybe kawana
was developing this over the board as a
four is really a total sideline yeah a5
is some yeah i'm not sure if it is
totally essential to play this move but
he wants to probably just push b5 next
and there is no really useful move in
preparation for that played be three and
now be five yeah um bishop took i was
thinking at first year what about this
move can you not just attack the rook
and where is it actually going on the
thing is black and can really ignore
that the ruckus is attacked there are
ways to sacrifice the exchange um one
being the simple captcha here after be
takes a four if whites now grabs
black has very nice compensation with
the two bishops and the pond cm this is
a quite interesting position it can also
be a row can also rise without the rooks
if white takes cm it's um it's the same
type of compensation it's only
questionable what what is better however
here this position black has very good
chances the very strong bishops a very
tough white very tough for why to handle
where do you actually go with with your
PCM the seaborne is especially dangerous
if you would give it to an engine like
Houdini it already gives black yeah
almost the better chances so grabbing
the exchange is probably not a good idea
agree shock took on b5 relatively
quickly and now 97 yeah black just says
ok out can take b5 at any time don't
need to do this right away ya know nitey
force plate him attacking these six note
that Grisha burned almost 45 minutes on
this move he got into a hair-raising
time travel in this game as he usually
does but it was it was some one of the
more extreme ones okay Queenie 72 to
cover the d6 ball and here after Bishop
g5 yeah black wants to keep these six
protected and he doesn't want to go back
to f8 with the Queen so Knight f6 was
unnecessary it's a bit strange to go
into this self pin but there is really
no way for white to ER to use it a
greased-up tried he played the Queen d3
attacking the rook on b5 the rook went
back and now Queen III this is a way to
try to use them the yeah somewhat
awkward pinning situation here with
the bishop and the knight on f6 but Kara
wanna has a surprising answer and a very
direct one he just plays h6 and yeah
this is in fact a strong move and leads
to to a fine position for black yeah
white now does not have much choice he
took on f6 we can we can look at other
move some what about Bishop takes h6
yeah like just takes and wins material
um all this is the alternative it will
get to a position where black has those
two passports and white has no big play
the the issue here is really very often
the bishop on g2 which is not in general
a bad piece it's very often useful to
support the center but here it's mostly
looking at this pawn on d5 and doing
nothing and this makes those passed
pawns even more dangerous a5 and c5 so
Bishop takes h6 is not a good idea what
why did is he took on f6 Bishop takes
and now it's very interesting bri sugars
already down five minutes here really
cool well Kara wanna has also and also
spend lots of time but it's not
comparable to this yeah now Grisha quent
Queen to f4 which is a somewhat strange
looking move why not capture on h6
immediately it has however a very deep
very deep point if we look at the game
in comparison to Queen takes h6 if you
take here and black takes on b3 what you
certainly will do in the game we have
the same position yeah the same position
but let me go back Queen a force plate
Bishop b5 to cover d6 and then it took
so it's the absolutely same position but
with inserting queen air for black has
provoked the move Bishop b5 and the
difference is really huge compare this
takes takes and now in the game he could
take on c5 using this technical motif to
get the c5 pawn it here this is not
possible because there is the funny move
Queenie five and now flex black ass is
strapping the Queen look at this and the
queen is trapped the difference is that
in the game variation there is a bishop
only five so there is not Queen e5
available so a very a subtle point this
happened and and now after the capture
d6 there is no Queen e5 as there is a
bishop and the caption see hive by the
way was playable for black it wasn't it
wasn't a bad move probably this d6 can
be answered with Queen a7 and if we look
at this position the capture on a eight
simply grabbing the rook after Queen a8
isn't particularly great for for white
the deep on it's not very dangerous that
can easily be stopped by the bishops and
black has two bishops against the rook
the queen is offside black is very very
much better here the problem is not this
capture the thing is why he has another
moose and this is the really funny move
Bishop to d5 attacking the rook and
setting up the Queen takes g6 idea
typical tactic with the bishop here in
the center on this on this diagonal
using the pin yeah in this position is
totally unclear I really don't know how
to assess it um for example and there
are alternatives Bishop g7 green g6
and then yeah well the rook needs to
move it's also attacked may be here
Andrew k3 may be intending to switch the
rook over yeah black as a brick is a
piece up but white has two pounds for
the piece and this yeah somewhat
menacing attacking position the the
engines suggest Bishop me six-year
returning a pawn check no and black gum
tries to defend this year with the Queen
it's a very tough very tough to to judge
in a practical game anything can happen
but to give an objective assessment this
is difficult um both Houdini and
stalkerish give give you the typical 000
which does not tell you very much it's
very complicated but I very much can
understand that Kara wanna didn't they
go for that after night xe5 he just
played a rook b5 after which 93 Bishop
g7 Queen d2 and a 4 it's looking very
logical and if you compare this to the
other position where your king is
running around and you really don't know
what's going on then I think this is
clearly preferable black he has
sacrificed them upon is a pawn down but
while what what kind of porn is he down
i mean the h7 porn essentially and this
is not really relevant to the things
happening on the board at the moment and
the main thing is the a pond is very
strong supported by those rooks and the
fantastic g7 been only bishop is raking
down the board if you see this in
comparison to the other line where your
king is well in danger and you
absolutely cannot assess what's going on
then it's pretty clear that you choose
that you choose this kind of line yeah
Grisha was now playing Quincy to end
with this way he quickly initiates
on a material transformation which I
think it's very understandable also
given the time situation is down to two
minutes this is increment ya get 30
seconds Pam boost but still yeah after a
three which is pretty much force this is
attacked twice why just took on a two
takes k and takes on c8 yeah this is
what Gris shock had planned he exchanges
this he gives up the exchange for the
apron and gets back c8 and he had this
position in mind here we can see a
situation with white having two pawns
for the exchange and position where
basically everything is protecting each
other the bishop p on a3 is protecting
ito e 2 is protecting the Bishop e2 is
protecting the night so everything is
nicely held together in whites position
and this makes them the whole thing
relatively easy to play with little time
on the clock so very good practical
decision white can basically in some way
just shuffle them here played f4 and
Blackwood f5 introduces some active
ideas maybe long-term but what weist is
doing mostly it's just keeping the
position as is king g to going on a
light square always an idea if blacks
pieces here on dark squares Queen f6
rook h1 it's just shuffling so on the
exchange sacrifice that Bishop played
was purely a defensive but it really
should be sufficient to keep the balance
Queen B 1 Andrew kb3 yeah and now here
in this situation with we shook down on
on seconds um he must play you must play
the Queen obviously the only thing what
he absolutely shouldn't do this what he
actually played you played the move
Queen to a two and after Queen a tu Cara
wanna in fact can win the game and he
also found it with not much time on the
clock if you want a not too difficult
technical exercise you can stop the
video here and look for a way for black
to to win the game I'll be silent for a
couple of seconds and then I'll play out
the move yeah what black was able to do
is the capture on d3 takes a droopy to
yeah and this is total disaster now the
queen is hanging and the rook and queen
are taking on f 2 so this is just total
win the Queen Queen on a 2 has no check
or whatever no counter play and wide
will just collapse on f2 so very sub end
to this game which after any other Queen
move basically that's not blundering the
Queen users may be being a queen to d1
um I don't think there should happen
anything because as mentioned White's
position is completely a yeah completely
coordinated there's no a palm break or
whatever that black ken can try um so
what would have been very likely a draw
if vishal gum wouldn't have blundered
tea on 38 and they have across the time
control that move 40 so if he would have
been able to navigate this last last
danger he probably would have drawn the
game relatively easily so um as a
summary for the first round we had four
draws games that have been have been
yeah played out nowhere
games without any any real play it
wasn't terribly exciting those those
drawers but you can't have fireworks all
the time yeah here in Greece you karana
we had an interesting opening middle
game face with some interesting tactics
and ultimately the time travel he have
decided as some as mentioned with only a
bit more time on the clock we showcase
certainty seeing this technical trick
and would have avoided it alright I hope
you like the coverage for round one
round two is played to write tomorrow
and of course I will again provide
coverage there thanks for watching